[Music]
you listen to inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum Hey wide camera hey close up
hey Ryan and Bryce and everybody out
there hope your you're enjoying your the
beginning of your week last week was
mental health week and for inside of you
and if you haven't listened to it you
should because it's free therapy and
these women are amazing therapists and I
hope I read the comments and it sounded
like everybody really really enjoyed it
and I'm so happy and they were my
therapists so and they are my therapists
and here exactly if I talked beforehand
about his how it saved his life and
saved mine and mine in a lot of ways but
but it's an on it's something that you
just have to keep doing and keep working
on yourself I don't think you just go to
therapy and go oh I'm fixed
if you don't implement you know routine
and structure in your life um also my
sister she's working hard right now
trying to you know keep routine and a
diet and all these things and wishing
her the best I like to see people just
putting one foot in front of the other
I get so down on myself because III
definitely uh you know you take a step
forward two steps back and it was a song
not take one step ahead I took two steps
back who was that I'm sure you're gonna
I was gonna tell me you guys are gonna
let me know um
just get overwhelmed the little things
I've got to figure that out why is it
that the little things I just go I can't
figure this out I can't figure this out
it's all yeah it's like all day but I I
just I don't like that feeling and then
I start saying why are you feeling like
this let's let's uh okay let's do
something about it let's [ __ ] breathe
take deep breaths walk outside get out
of your head [ __ ] I do it and I do it
thank you again for listening make sure
you subscribe to the podcast the social
handles on Instagram inside of you at
inside your podcast and the Twitter and
Satya pod we're also on Facebook write a
review subscribe please watch the
youtubes if you're listening
it really helps for many reasons that
you might not even understand thank you
to all the lovely patrons I'm wearing
pants today I decided today I'm gonna
wear pants
so I don't know I'm excited about it I'm
excited about pants
I feel more together maybe what you
dresses who you are I don't think that's
true maybe it is maybe you feel a bit
more confident I'm if you you know put
clothes on I don't know what I'm talking
about
the podcast live podcast in Austin Texas
with Zach leave I've scheduled for July
2nd at the north door
we're rescheduling that because of this
whole pandemic and everything else
that's going on and so it will happen
just this getting pushed a little bit
we'll let you know on the podcast and my
Instagram handles stage it's thank you
guys for checking out my friend Rob
Danson and I he was my guitarist and
left and Laurel we had a we played two
shows live on stage it this past
Saturday at 2 o'clock shown a 6 o'clock
show was fantastic and we thank
everybody for for bidding and all this
crap but it's not crap but also the
inside of you store you wanted to get
any merch new sweatshirts and new cool
shirts inside you store calm and patron
if you haven't joined patreon it's an
amazing community just go to patreon and
calm inside of you patreon and check out
all the cool things it's great community
you'll meet new friends and you get
bonus material and a bunch of cool stuff
from the show and also the other patreon
I have is an exclusive where have all
the good horror movies gone with my good
friend Jon Heder in Napoleon Dynamite
and we talked our movies reviews we this
tons of fun [ __ ] just go check it out
it's easy I think that's pretty much it
you know by the way you know I could sit
here and talk about all these things
that are going on in the world and the
thing is you hear them I think you know
you know I care you know I have a lot of
love I put instagrams out there I donate
I do whatever I can I feel like you know
on my podcast I just try not to get
political I try not to get I just want
you guys to
[Music]
you know anxiety and depression aren't
something that could be political I mean
they are I mean because there needs to
be more done about mental health but
what I'm saying is this is a show where
I hope you learn from my guest and you
get something out of it and we talk
about things that you know they faced so
so if I don't talk politics I hope you
don't get mad but it's just I don't know
enough about them anyway and I'll end up
sounding like an idiot and so I just
choose not to this guest is hilarious
I've seen him do comedy I've done
stand-up comedy with him he's got a huge
podcast bad friends Andrew Santino funny
man
we really talked about it's nice to hear
about that you know his family life how
it all happened for him his attitude
towards the media
and I really enjoyed this one he's a
he's a funny guy so I hope you enjoy
this as much as I did
let's get into Andrew Santino it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience oh my god Santini the great
saying how many times have you heard the
the great Santino yeah it's terrible
I've heard that before
it's just what's terrible just original
because the Great Santini was a magician
Santino is a respectful this is a
respectful comedian so you're gonna say
he's a respectful comedian I'm a
respectful comedian and my last and the
last name is it means something Santino
means massive foot
I don't I don't believe that it does
look it up massive foot an Italian
Santana but there was a movie called the
Great Santini yeah the Great Santini is
magician Sam Santini was a magician but
that's not what I'm I'm saying I'm
saying there was a movie called The
Great Santini wasn't about a musician a
magician what was it about it was about
the Great Santini he was uh he was uh in
the military and he was like really hard
on his family oh my god hold on one
second I've got my Robert Duvall look at
my housemaid just brought me my steak
and eggs thank you house made your house
mate my house made my maid yeah she
comes down to my sex dungeon and brings
me she's gonna be mad that's my wife is
she's gonna be pissed off that I made
that joke that's it that's it for me
will she really be upset by that no no
she won't she doesn't have a choice
she puts up with a lot from you yeah but
good though right I'm asking you that I
mean she does she puts up with a ton
from me I'm gonna eat during his I feel
like this is up for only appropriate
cause of what's going on in the world to
eat during this yeah
that's cuz I was um I was marching all
night that's a lie I don't believe you
were out there now we live in the
suburbs did you protest at all honestly
I didn't go down there now the jus do I
feel should I feel bad is I've sold mean
eating we don't have to record right now
I just wanted to say hi to you for a
second before we go well you eat for a
minute I want to eat and talk let's just
eat and talk and see what we get out of
this
what were you really feeling about this
whole thing
honest it's all over the place
immediately pissed off and just
disgusted when I see that guy kneeling
on George Floyd's neck and and yeah him
begging for his life just honestly
disgusted there's no is a you can't I I
can't believe anyone would have a
different opinion on that I just I won't
even hear it I don't think anybody does
I think if anybody does it's all it's
all fabrication for this for the
sensationalizes sensationalism of media
and and and just for clickbait you know
what I mean like if somebody put
something out there being like this
isn't that bad it's them clickbait they
just want to get attention to whatever
they're doing I don't buy that anyone
doesn't see stuff like that and doesn't
get disgusted or gets sick I just don't
I don't buy well I I'm sure there are
people out there who are just so racist
that they're they love it maybe yeah
yeah there's some people out there
that's unfortunately you
that's sort of my point is like you're
not gonna change the sickos you're not
gonna change the people who look at
someone differently because the color of
the skin your net were never gonna
change that
there's no we're not gonna just wake up
it doesn't matter I mean I think it
doesn't matter who your leader is but I
just don't there's it's how you're
raised if I ever said the n-word or a
gay thing and from my parents a gay joke
my parents wouldn't stand for that [ __ ]
they just wouldn't stand that comedians
you can do certain things I'm telling
you that [ __ ] didn't fly in my house you
couldn't make an off-color joke in your
home that just wasn't the way it goes
nah I couldn't say something that was
derogatory I mean look I think everybody
like you hear it people say it you're
kids you're trying to fit in you're
doing things I grew up in Indiana but
overall I just didn't think like that I
wasn't it's it's how you're raised man
you know my parents I think if they
would have been think about it like how
many people agree with what their
parents say if their parents are
conservative they become conservative if
their parents are liberal hippies or
whatever they sort of have that liberal
mentality don't you agree with that to a
degree but then I think also there's
that teenage felt like teenage angst oh
[ __ ] yeah often times people come back
around to you know being how their
parents are but also if you're educated
enough or you're smart enough or you
have enough insight I think when it
comes down to honestly because education
gets thrown around people like all if
you're educated I I genuinely think my
opinion is people who either sounds
cliche but people who travel
and I mean that innocence not not like
well no I'm not saying like I went to
Spain for my senior trip you know like
no I mean like when you get out of your
own area element yeah even if you travel
to two states away and you see other
cultures and other people and how they
live I think you begin to open up your
mental state as far as like oh there's a
lot of different there's a lot of
different kinds of subcultures across
this country and you think about that as
a microcosm of the world but who does
that what percentage of people I don't
know anybody in Indiana or Kentucky or
they know where I grew up went to
college many most folks just stuck
around there that was the whole thing I
almost stayed there and worked at
grocery store or pump gas that I was
gonna do that so most people don't get
out imagine you as a gas pumper would be
incredible you would have been the best
gas pumper the most handsome gas pumper
on this side of the mason-dixon you
think so yeah man you're a handsome nice
chin you got a great teeth yeah dude no
I agree with you I think a lot of people
don't travel but outside of their own
comfort zone but I think it's more than
I think that's more than education I
think you can be educated about the
history and the trauma of this country
racially and still not really feel that
different about it because your bubble
is really nice
and when you get out of your bubble I
think is the only way that you can
actually see how the world operates I
mean that whether that influences you
negatively or positively well you know
you say that and you know what I think
about is this if your parents suck if
your parents teach you to hate if they
teach you to say that oh this this color
is these these are bad people these are
these are look at these these were
superior hopefully hopefully you have
some really amazing teachers that that
tell you differently and they and you
and you go with what they say you know
so hopefully if you have shitty teachers
and you have shitty parents you're
[ __ ]
your parents were teachers well no no no
what were your parent my dad had no
patience we meet my teacher what were
your parents how do you not know that
bath problem are you an idiot
I can do this backwards that's my dog
what did your dad do he worked at a
pharmaceutical company you know so big
pharma I mean you know he was like a
plant he became a plant manager so well
growing up like he worked at
pharmaceutic umpah knees and he was
making no money we're living in duplexes
in New York and then Connecticut and
finally when moved to Indiana things
started to get better for us what city
in Indiana Evansville Indiana I know it
well as a Chicago kid we have a lot of
love for Indiana that's where we could
go buy cigarettes and gas for cheap I
love Chicago
you go to the boy you cross the border
you get yourself some cigarettes you get
gas you can get all sorts of stuff
Indiana was always so much cheaper than
Chicago it was always such a nice little
uh a respite for for the price eNOS of
the city and then if people from Indiana
came in Chicago we liked them because
they were simple folk yeah by the way I
love I love the people I go back and I
just I have a lot of good friends and
family the blood of people I just love
to see and just you know what it is when
you go back I don't know if you feel
this way when you go back to Chicago you
go back to Indiana immediately I don't
know what it is you just kind of feel
like oh dude I love going home I'm
waiting for the day that I can get rich
enough to just move and leave LA and not
have to be here anymore
I like LA a lot but I just want to go
home sometimes I think that's how I'm
sort of getting to that point where I
just you say I think I look at you tell
me we're inside of you today
santino great same to you know but you
know coming from like Illinois coming
from like these this Midwestern
atmosphere and then coming out here and
then becoming a big comedian and getting
a big show and do movies and TV and all
these things like don't you think you've
lost some of yourself honestly do you
think you've become something that
you're like God you know I like it's not
that I hate myself but there's a certain
element that I just feel like I'm
forcing things or I'm or I'm just always
anxious or I'm always trying to be
better and in the best and in chasing
something like that anything that makes
life a little shitty er I don't know I
mean I could I don't know what else I
would be doing like what else am I gonna
do well I'm not saying that I'm saying
more more like the just the that
pressure the pressure of you know being
great the pressure of success yeah but I
guess what I'm saying what am i guess my
what I'm saying by that is like
if I didn't have that pressure who would
I what would I be this is the only thing
that drives me that fuels me as far as
like a career goes as a human being I
think I haven't changed my my compass
hasn't changed as far as what I like and
dislike and my morals and ethics I think
those things kind of stayed pretty solid
I don't think any of that stuff changed
when I came out here at all but I think
like you know I I just feel like this is
the only thing I've ever loved and ever
been good at so the negatives that come
along with it like all the pressure and
all that stuff it's a part of the thing
because that's the payment you have to
pay to live the life that we get to live
which is I get to [ __ ] make people
laugh for money it's the [ __ ]
greatest gig on earth so I don't so I
don't care that it comes with a lot of
anxiety I don't care that it comes with
some sacrifices in life because anything
great or anything worth it you're gonna
have to sacrifice name any person that's
done anything of any substance that
didn't sacrifice something doesn't exist
yeah so I just feel like if if losing
certain elements of my life
are the sacrifice for this freedom that
I get to just like use my brain to make
money and make people laugh and that's
like my literal job then [ __ ] I'll
take the sacrifice do you let it
overwhelm you does your wife ever say
you you've got to go see a therapist or
you've got you've got to go go for a run
you've got to work out you got to do
something you're honestly too much yeah
but I kind of checked myself now I know
better I run almost every day like
anywhere from like Fordyce four to seven
miles a day so that's my I do that
myself like I know when I'm overwhelming
and I'm like all right I gotta go and I
just take off I do it all the time I go
for a drive I know when I'm too much but
like I don't ever I find if it's
damaging me or my friendships or
relationships or whatever you know and
you just have to like give you put
yourself in timeout and just kind of
step back a little bit you know like
I've never let it I never I've never let
Hollywood take over me an urban like you
know [ __ ] my friends I'm just gonna you
know I'm gonna be on this solo path and
do it now but has my work ethic or Drive
or whatever kind of been a hindrance on
personal and and love relationships
absolutely but this come again comes
with the territory I don't think I've
sacrificed anything major for it you
know I've never like I've never
destroyed something just so I could
build myself up more so I've never done
that but I think it all comes with the
territory
you know what I mean I think that she
knows she's been along for the ride for
a long time so she knows the nonsense
that comes along with this of late
nights of the going out and doing shows
and everyday working and weekends you're
gone and I think they I think she
understands you know I mean it's it's on
it you kind of queue you know you it's a
it's a compromise for sure on the the
wife or husband of a comedian is it's
such a compromise you have to know what
they're getting into it's it's tough but
it's like if you're aware of it and
you're honest about it and you're not
because I get up so my god Rosa mom oh
yeah center of attention I just be like
[ __ ] you I love to [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and then I realize no you are you
[ __ ] idiot that's part of you you
want to go into a room and you're
insecure about something your looks your
personality so what do you do
I want everybody of the thing I'm funny
and then they'll like me that's been
embedded
me since I'm a kid so I think once you
accept those flaws and no matter what
people say about them you're like okay
you can't let them hurt you because
they're actually would hurt you is
usually true isn't it yeah I mean that's
probably that's where the insecurity
comes from something about it is real
but it's funny that as you get older the
insecurity is um the insecurities change
you know like when you're a kid like
when I'm a kid it's like all red hair
fire-crotch all that stuff that you're
like it like I annoyed about and then
you get older it's like that stuff
couldn't hurt me if you try I mean
there's no there's no name you could
make fun of me that would hurt my
feelings just like really did I've
there's nothing you don't know this is I
hurt me more than you could ever hurt
what about swollen foot foot but no sin
I don't know what Santino really means I
kind of want to look it up now that I
lied to you about that do you [ __ ] I'm
naive I'm so gullible I know I know
well actually Santino is um
Santino is a meaning of the name and I
apologize for eating on this I just
haven't eaten fine and this segments
gonna really bore people so tell us what
Santino means they're gonna really love
to hear those the name of the meaning
Santino
there we go folks etymology historic
Santino is the Italian pet form of Santo
the Italian word for Saint that's right
okay see it so it means sacred st.
Santino essentially means little Saint
to do a diminutive form Santino means
little Saint or just Saint so um I'm the
[ __ ] and what does Rosenbaum mean I
think it means let another Jewish guy
read tree one more Jew that's what it
means red tree I you know it's funny
because my I got a friend yarv oh he
always looks at me cuz he look way more
Nazi no I Jesus Christ because I mean no
I mean you look like just Aryan you look
like more more than that than Jew and
I'm like I don't even know what to say
about this Rosenbaum means ROH yeah it's
me it's a German word German red tree
red tree it's Rosenbaum Rosenbaum
Dakin ZFS dodge cummins he lays
non-striving yeah yeah lickin on Minhaj
is copying the hooks in your mouth I
[ __ ] my pants that's what I said are you
no I'm not I hate Nazis [ __ ] but
you're Jewish right
because I can't do this if you're not
Jewish I'm George of course I'm Jewish
okay yeah cuz I think you're not Jewish
it's like that's a waste of my time to
be now do you think you're doing things
now you're in a place where you kind of
say whatever not to say it's shock value
but sometimes you just say whatever the
[ __ ] on your mind what you always like
that even in college or whenever you
start to stand up do you think you kind
of found your voice you're like this is
what works for me well I think I always
said what I felt but you just I just
wasn't as good at it back then you know
like you're just I'm just I just wasn't
a good stand up when you start no one's
good I mean the only kid that's there
was probably good when they started
through historical or was probably like
Chapelle you know a lot of people say
Chapelle when he was 16 was a phenom
like he was ahead of his time I think
his intelligence level was through the
roof he just understood stuff at a young
age but know most almost every comic you
love and know is not good when they
start so I knew what I wanted to say I
just didn't know how to say it and was
going through in terms of like when you
were first starting out were there times
where you wanted to quit I suck were you
getting anxiety did you get down on
yourself no you know I always I mean I
knew I was I mean it sounds um pretty
you know not humble but like I knew I
was better than most of my peers like it
was very obvious at a young age when you
start stand-up that you go okay out of
the 50 people that I know that I
constantly see it open mics or whatever
around town I'm one of the top 10 of
these people and you just know it you
don't I mean you just kind of like can
feel where people rank and you don't
really talk about it as time goes on it
becomes more obvious then I think that's
material or do you think it's a
combination of like do you think your
energy was just better your persona or
do you think it was the material or both
both of them when you're young I think
everyone's material is [ __ ] when you
start out as a comic your material is
bad you just don't know what to talk
about you haven't had a lot a lot of
life experience you know that's why
there's not a lot of good 22 you how
many great 22 year old comedians do you
know you don't I mean it's like you
haven't lived enough life you haven't
felt enough onstage you haven't been
through enough both in the comedy world
and in your personal life to really
cultivate something that's worth
listening to
unless of course you have again I go
back to Chappelle who like I think he
was such a phenom because he lived an
interesting life and he saw the world
from from two very interesting lenses of
like growing being born and raised in DC
and then moving to Ohio and he talks
about it a lot like you go from like
being a young black man in a you know
very racially integrated city with a lot
of disparity of money and the dispersion
of wealth and DC is a is a very [ __ ]
crazy city of like the richest of the
rich and the poorest of the poor are
four blocks away
and when I say riches the rich I'm
talking old money not like the guy in
Beverly Hills who has a house in the
hills that guy's [ __ ] DC is like
nine generations of wealth you know then
you moved to Ohio where it's
predominantly white and he had to
experience I think these both I'm
telling his story but like I just think
that's rare you're saying it's rare it's
rare for someone young unless you have
lived which at that point he had some of
that in him which made him good and he
was just a gifted it was an anomaly
extremely gifted yeah but were you yes
him have lived that much one with that
young what were you rate like did you
like your parents are your parents good
were they nice do they love you did they
all that [ __ ] I mean I killed him when I
was 12 so I don't really I don't know
much about him anymore I uh
I beat my mom with my dad I picked him
up and I hope and I know my parents are
great people they're good people I mean
I they say I had a very normal I mean
and it's a sense normal childhood as
much as it could be my parents are
divorced and then my mom got remarried
but I call my stepdad my dad he's my guy
and I and he treated me like a son you
know like he true so I oh I didn't have
a disadvantage of like daddy issue if I
have daddy issues it's because my real
father who's you know not really it
wasn't really in my life but I had a
stepdad who was just a good a great dude
to me who treated me like a son do you
feel like your your your real dad not
being around not you do you feel like
you have any kind of residual effects
from that do you feel like abandonment
issues at all from that I mean IIIi
therapists would probably say yeah you
know psychologically I'm sure there's
something deep inside you but I don't
recognize it as an adult
like I don't consciously recognize it
because my life is good with the parents
that I that I have you know like I used
to always say to people to say oh you're
real dad I'd be like well my real dad is
my real dad my stuff that is my real
like my biological father is the guy
that you know I have I share blood with
but my real dad is my stepdad that's my
real dad because did he ever reach out
when you
more success did he ever say hey we've
kept in contact over the years I talked
to him four or five days ago we keep it
we keep in contact and very large in
like big waves you know I mean like I
look at it like I literally look at it
like like like waves in the ocean like
sometimes I catch it sometimes I don't
you know sometimes we don't catch away
for a long time sometimes we'll talk
four to three weeks on end every few
days and kind of be in conversation and
then months and months will go by and
then we won't speak does he know how you
feel probably not truthfully probably no
I mean he I think he's I think he gets
it I think he understands how I feel but
I don't think he's I've never sat and
talked with him about it but it's also
because
I thought what would it I don't know
what it would do for me do you don't I
mean like yeah I've said that to my wife
it's like I'm I'm fine like I I'm I'm
happy with the family that I have and I
wish no ill will on the dude I I got
love for him in my heart cuz he's my
blood but also um I don't know I'm like
I'm grown you don't I mean like when you
grow up you're kind of like I'm already
I'm a man I'm you know what you rent you
know I don't know about that I'm still
figuring that [ __ ] out man
you're a boy you're a boy you're a boy
you're gonna be blowing that no but you
know I partum he's like you know I think
in my feeble mind uh you know I wonder
what would it be like if let's say that
was my situation if I'd want my father
one day to just say hey I want to say
these things to you right now
I was this I was that I'm apologizing
you deserve better you got a great
whatever everything you wanted to hear
but maybe you don't need to hear that
yeah I mean I don't think I do I don't
want to I mean an intensive like it
doesn't really it doesn't really matter
to me I don't that sounds so so
disrespectful it doesn't really don't
I'm cool with it
you know what I mean like I'm like yeah
we're well I was gonna say you know that
song cat in the cradle
you know cat's cradle in the silver the
story of my life of like it's like hey
Dad hey Dad hey Dad and dad's like oh
you know I'll be back someday I'll be
back soon I gotta go work and then when
a dad gets older and he's like hey
sounds like I just like me yeah he's
like I got my own family I'm doing my
own saying dude I gotta go
but do you think you do that
subconsciously to sort of like as a
defense mechanism deep down where it's
like hey I'm busy I got my own [ __ ] I'm
gonna keep busy busy busy because a lot
of people if they stop for a second they
go oh [ __ ] and I feel like I might be
one of those people I know friends that
they don't they stop for a second
depression kicks in anxiety kicks in yes
sometimes but in this case in regards to
that it's more like
I just
I don't do I don't do it out of spite or
anything I do it just because I'm like I
do I just have my own things going on
like I'm just kind of like you know I've
got my own [ __ ] I don't know I've got
like my oh so much of my own [ __ ] that
it's like we're just two men that's how
I look at it like you he's just a do
it's like saying sometimes I call
friends and sometimes I don't talk to
him for a long time you know my oldest
friend in the world I talk to him every
once in a while and then sometimes we'll
catch up a lot and then sometimes we
will I feel like it's the same
relationships just two men as men get
older you just start to realize that
like friendships friendships are these
things that like you you you keep
nurturing as much as you can and if you
don't talk to each other for a while
it's all good and then when you come
back to it yeah if you're mature enough
you'll understand what it is and you
won't hold any like yeah dude where have
you been wherever like there's more of
like a hey dude you're busy you're this
but you know I'm here and there's an
understanding and I have friends like
that where I don't see him all the time
but there's a love and some friends you
know I gotta be honest I don't hang out
with a lot of people it's just I people
would say I have so many friends because
I do I have lots of friends but the
people that I really hang out with like
I just altima Lee I deal with anxiety I
deal with [ __ ] and I want people around
me that you're sort of like I don't want
people around me that just kiss my ass I
don't want that I just want people that
make me feel like I could just lie down
watch TV and not think of entertaining
anybody do you have a lot of friends
outside of the business um you know I
have friends back home a couple friends
back home and nobody here though in LA
that are not in the biz oh yeah yeah my
best friend growing up who was like he
was my mentor I mean did the guy he was
a popular kid in high school and he came
up he's to come up to my house and I was
like this shortest kid my high school
picked on or whatever and he used to
always say hey kind of my I think I've
told the story Beesly
hey come on having people over my
parents are out of town and I'd show up
and I hear other [ __ ] going why is
this [ __ ] here I hear it and and and
hear Tom go he's cool man he's cool and
I remember when he came up to my house
my senior year and goes hey dude I'm
thinking to go into Western Western
Kentucky I go yeah well why don't you
guys want to be my roommate on a room
and I'm like yeah you're popular I'm not
this could be a way in and I went and
applied to [ __ ] whatever you do what
do you you know apply you uh apply you
apply to college no it's not the word
it's a you don't you apply to school
yeah you ply I guess she do I shouldn't
have gone to school cuz I don't know
that and I got in and we were roommates
and he became sort of like dude this
guy's funny watch him do this impression
hey I used to make money doing
impressions with a with a little bucket
and we'd make enough money to have
breakfast at Murray's the next morning
in Kentucky anyway so I have him he's
been my life long friend I have a note
that he wrote me in an envelope back in
90 [ __ ] 6 when you're 32 and not know
when I'm [ __ ] mid-20s or 45 you were
40 [ __ ] what do you know you're 16
I'm 47 and it's a habit downstairs and
it's framed with a like it's just some
kind of a collage and it just says
you'll never understand I'm you you have
my undying friendship forever whatever
it's something just really beautiful and
means a lot to you but you don't know
what it says that's that's why I didn't
memorize the [ __ ] thing I have a
great memory Santini's no but listen so
do you have those friends that because I
have a say a lot of my close close
friends aren't in the business I have
celebrity friends like you know Bobby
Lee you're my friend you know we don't
know each other that well but I can see
like hey I do have a beard anyway I
don't hang out with tons of celebrities
yeah most of my friend my closest group
of friends in Los Angeles aren't in the
business I mean they're ancillary but
they're not like they don't do what we
do they're not they're not on our side
of it they're on the other side of the
camera there but like a lot of guys here
work in production or they write yeah
yeah yeah my closest group of friends
that we hang out with the most yeah I
know they don't they're just they're in
the business but when I say that I mean
like they're not actors or comics or
directors or producers they're just
people that work in the business on the
other side so my that's my closest
Cooper friends and outside of comics I
mean you know by the way I want to talk
to you about this how do you deal with
criticism how do you he'll deal with
hecklers how do you deal with people who
don't think you're funny
trolls how do you deal with those guys
I've talked about a pretty openly I
don't give I don't care even a little
bit if you don't like my stuff I always
say J this is my suggestion to people
that like um that are that like I get
online and hate like you have every
right to like be like oh you suck I hate
you I don't like your [ __ ] fine okay
that's fine then after that moment that
you say you don't like me then
Sapir me from your conscious forever
dissing me don't even don't watch me
again don't follow me don't talk to me
don't comment it's that easy if I go to
a restaurant and I hate the food I'm
just not gonna go back why don't you get
back eat again and go yeah see I knew I
didn't like this food like yeah dummy
don't ever come back if you don't like
me don't come back I don't I don't give
a [ __ ] it means nothing to me that you I
think people want to be significant and
they realize they're insignificant so
when they're mean online it gives them
some sort of significance because
usually it attracts other people to talk
[ __ ] back right when somebody writes
something negative on any of our pages
on mine or on bad friends or whatever
our fans will just attack them and I'm
oh I always delete it because I'm like
no don't waste your time fighting for me
over this [ __ ]
just let them be a sad [ __ ] by
themselves these people are gonna die a
sad shitty life and I just don't care
about them if your whole life is
consumed with being with talking [ __ ]
about things you don't like online like
without any sense of like you know
jovial Nisour just kidding around or
like if it's just it's just these are
these like literal attacks on people
online which happens those are just sad
lonely people they're hurt they're hurt
and they need something to make up for
their hurt I like the analogy that the
restaurant that's the best thing you got
a restaurant this food sucks don't go
back and if you do go back once and it
sucks again certainly don't go back to
third time I just don't go back but yeah
what I deal with it in the way that any
of us do which is like it exists there's
people they're gonna not like your [ __ ]
dude all the time you know people gonna
say I don't think you look I had some
guy wait in line I wasn't heathen I
don't think he was being mean I don't
know what he was doing was that a
convention and he was in line I always
take times with my fans and I'm talking
to him he just goes he waits in line for
like 20 minutes
I mean Prai v my lines aren't that big
but he comes up and then he goes gene
Hackman's the best Lex Luthor and I go I
agree absolutely he goes oh all right
well he's walking I've talked about that
but it's just like I don't I really
don't care I honestly don't get upset I
just did a roll and I hope people liked
it and that's it I just do the best that
Janan and did look does it hurt my
feelings I'm a human being did when I
read if I breed a bad review and it goes
there was an article once it says
so-and-so's not funny so-and-so's not
funny Michael Rosenbaum will never be
funny just I don't even know what it was
and I go what the [ __ ] I don't read that
[ __ ]
sometimes you think something so good
like that you did that it's only gonna
be praised but no there's gonna don't
want yeah but but don't but don't don't
look for the praise or the negative like
I know that sounds cliche but like I've
said this openly all the time I give
zero goose egg I give goose egg credit
to critics they mean nothing to me I
don't give a [ __ ] about what critics
think about my work you can publish that
you can [ __ ] staple it to the wall I
don't give a [ __ ] what any critic will
ever write about me for the rest of my
[ __ ] life I don't care what your
character on Dave didn't he go up to a
it's a character event if you go up to
the guy the guy go hey yeah you wouldn't
[ __ ] sign me [ __ ] was not you I don't
give a [ __ ] about critics I'd you know I
care about the fans of course I care
about people that pay good hard-earned
money to come watch me to come support
me to be a part of my journey as I try
to entertain people and I'm not being
I'm being extremely genuine I've learned
so much in the past couple of years to
like really appreciate the fans and
people that are like yo I like you why
would you pay attention to people that
say they don't like I've only heard
honestly I I don't hear anything bad
about you I'm not kidding it's not like
I don't know you that well but I'm
telling you like Bobby Lee there's a
very close friend of mine and yours of
course love and you know Bobby has a
huge heart but what people don't
understand about Bobby is that Bobby
will not hang out with people who make
him feel shitty or aren't so you guys go
at it on bad friends and you say and I
want to get into that but like Bobby if
he didn't like you he would
it just wouldn't want to be anywhere
near you and so if Bobby loves you that
means a lot to me well he him and I have
such a great relationship because he
knows that anything we get at each other
just because our personalities clash and
that's why the show I think works and I
but for us the truth is like we have so
much love like he he goes back with me
in the comedy story I mean he's really
one of the reasons that I got into the
system early on because Bobby used to
tell the old man
he was like you gotta watch Santino you
got to watch Santino and it's just cuz
we loved each other you know like we
always we always would get at each other
but it's just because we really really
like each other
he said something you guys were talking
about me on the podcast yeah I got a
call that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's weird cuz
he does he sticks up for his friends
he's a great dude who cares about the
right things he needs to care less about
the some of the other stuff like he's
somebody I tell all time like he reads
the comments he gets in his heads he
gets in fights with people he thinks
what people say is valid you know when
some jagoff is like Bobby Lee is not
funny or or or says something negative
about anything he's ever done he takes
it to heart and I'm like Bob it that it
means nothing you cannot pay attention
to someone just saying something to try
to hurt your feelings you know like he
does that way too much and I'm trying to
get him to be better about it but it's
difficult inside of you is brought to
you by fair harbor fair harbor it's the
first article of clothing their swimming
trunks that I wear and I wear them every
day my friends have ordered them this is
a product that I stand behind I know
you're gonna love it they're replacing
all their mesh lining so you know that
mesh line that shapes you and makes you
just uncomfortable they have the softest
boxer-brief liner you'll ever have it's
embarrassing cuz I talked to my dad
about it Mike oh my gosh he's had these
liners in it dad your balls just feel
he's like Michael come on now I talking
about your balls in front your dad I'm
telling you this stuff's great just try
it if you don't like it I'll give you
something I know you're gonna love it
all fair harbor products are made from
recycled plastic bottles this is a
sister brother team and they have
recycled over 2.5 million plastic
bottles keeping plastic out of waterways
and off beaches incredible may make cool
clothing they're saving the beaches I
mean they're heaven bound heaven bound
that's what I'm saying fair harbor makes
products for you to enjoy the places you
love while protecting those places at
the same time 20 percent off for
everyone listening right now 20 percent
off head over to fair harbor clothing
comm use the code inside 20 for 20
percent off that's inside 20
and say goodbye to mesh lining forever
when you guys are doing your show it's
obvious to me that you do most of the
work like Bobby just shows up what are
you talking about me shows them ago
sorry what are we talking about today
and you kind of have to it's it's funny
because it's the perfect dynamic it's
the perfect like you're like going off
on something he's like why and then
he'll just question you on it do you
guys plan things out I mean because it's
got to be hard because it's a successful
podcast it's big I mean you know bad
friends but like you're talking for an
hour sometimes an hour and 20 and do you
do you have you done that besides we
like that I just I don't know just
wasn't funny that this episode didn't
work so the episode that we put out I
don't know when this is coming up with
the episode we put out today June 1st
was tough we took we took a few days to
do it we've never done this before we
usually do it in one day together but we
took three days we tried it once but
that was a flub and then we tried it
again and there was a motions were
rising because of what's going on and
the what's going on right now and then
we had to do it again to kind of just
like fair talk very candidly and openly
about you know I think this was a
special circumstance like we usually
knock it out we have a great time and
the rhythm is good and it just flows for
an hour and a half sometimes you know an
hour and you piece it together like you
wore the same shirts three days in a row
or did you just try it new every time
one day we threw in the trash we threw
the first day in the trash and then the
second day we just had to yeah we just
had to go over some stuff that we wanted
to just clarify because at the end of
the day we were exhausted we were just
like tired and we were annoyed and
emotions were high and so we were kind
of like we in order with each other did
you fight with each other no no I mean
emotions were high in the sense that we
were like angry and annoyed and [ __ ]
up about this whole thing and like
really didn't know how to feel and
didn't know how to talk about it because
we're a comedy show and at the end of
the day I was like this is a [ __ ]
comedy show you know we're trying to be
funny and Bobby was upset he was like I
feel off I feel mentally tough exhausted
and I'm angry and I'm annoyed and I like
it kind of affected what we were putting
out and I was like we want to put out a
good product and I said to him I said
you know Bobo if you want to like tape
again tomorrow
let's just come back when you we feel
better when you could go to yoga get
more sleep and he did and it worked it
was nice and I'm I'm the same way I
wasn't feeling good about it I was
annoyed I was frustrated I didn't know
how to talk about stuff because I just
hear here's why there's so much to say
and there's no way to do it the right
there's no way to properly say it all so
I was frustrated it's like there's so
much to say about it so so so you keep
current topics like you know I've you
guys kind of just rant and go off and
you say things like you know you did a
Trump thing you did whatever you know
split screen kind of like you know Biden
was answering you know you were a
handsome and that was it was funny and
Bobby's like that's not funny and then
you're going it's funny that just the
dichotomy or whatever the dynamic you
know we usually plan there are some bits
that are very produced and planned that
we make sure we bring to the table that
we can talk about but sometimes they get
thrown in the trash and we just like we
go from wherever we're going how many
people are involved in this I know
there's you and Bobby and then there's
you have a producer how many producers
do you have as far as like episode
production it's it's me and Bob I mean
um when I say me and Bob I mean it's me
no it's it's we like it's me it's me and
Bobby it's me and Bobby and George and
andreas sometimes have suggestions for
the show that's great you know they help
but they're most that stuff is a lot of
post-production a lot of like editing
and a lot of the graphic design comes
from these two people that we use that I
used for my for whiskey ginger for my
show
Joseph Faria and Jenna Sunday I so they
were my people for whiskey ginger and I
brought them over to bad friends they're
the ones that do like the thumbnails and
a lot of digital art that you see that
gets thrown up and a lot of like the
great segments that we put up they do
all of the art for that so there are
artists do you think that's important
for like you know for instance you know
I have a podcast I just film it me and
the me and the guest then that's what
it's just a different kind of show tell
you know you guys have sort of a talking
show and it's produced and it looks like
you know you you put something into it
it's not just you go in there recording
it's done somebody edits it it seems
like there's a lot more to it
podcasting is not that it's not that
easy and everybody has a [ __ ] but the
other day I looked on another actors got
a [ __ ] podcast like how are you how
do you get people this [ __ ] it's a time
I mean we do that show for that reason
like I think it is fun for us to do
produce bits and be kind of like
make it a show I like making it a show I
mean I think it's fun to be a [ __ ]
show it's two of us so it's like the
show is me and Bobo it's like that's the
show and so producing bits for it is
very entertaining and very fun so we
have a team that helped us out and
George and andreas edit and we have Rudy
his anis is in the room with us and a
woman who have very few words but when
she says something it just cracks she's
a gift from like the comedy God because
she's it's not funny
she's our inside mole dude our little
inside track and well so yeah we have a
good team of people that like help out
make the show visually look the way it
looks but from the inside perspective of
the bits a lot of most of it's just me
and Bobby kind of formulating what to
talk about week to week and yeah man
it's dude it's the most fun I said this
the other day to my wife it's the most
fun I've ever had in comedy since I was
an open mic ER I mean that like dude I
played theatres of my own that I've sold
out I played an Arena I played arenas
with Joe Rogan I've done arenas of
people like you know it's funny because
when I'm watching I'm like going who
what friend could I get to do something
along these lines no I really thought it
I go but yeah not the same thing but
just two personalities that we kind of
riff on what's going on in the world and
I was like who who would because you
guys have a very tight group like just I
mean you have get you out you guys all
came up together people like oh they've
got this clique well you guys have all
been friends for a long time you D'Elia
Rogan Bobby Lee
Christ sure even right yeah but it's
just to grew in those guys they come
it's all kind of form this like weird
little podcast group but like it was
organic I mean I say it all the time
the Bobby and I show was not born from
anything but the fans I people talk
there's this running joke as Eric
Griffin asked Bobby to do a show with
him years ago and it never happened
because he started doing Tiger belly and
then you know some of the fans we joke
around that it's like oh [ __ ] you know
stole the show from Eric Griffin but the
truth is I have my own show whiskey
ginger does very well for me and they
have tiger belly and the fans anytime I
did belly the fans were like you guys
need to start a show in kalila Bobby's
love of his life was like you should you
guys should really do the show together
the fans keep saying it so it wasn't
like we didn't the only time I went out
of my way was when I physically made it
happen was when I went and got the
studio you know we started to put the
equipment together which you know that's
I did all that [ __ ] because I was like
alright let's try this if it works it
worked if not not but I didn't
consciously do this as like I'm making a
podcast Bobby we got to do this together
this was the fans were like dude the
show do the show they kept telling us to
do a show so we were like okay let's try
it and it worked it wasn't a this wasn't
some great plan of attack that we had in
mind you don't I mean I'm jealous I
should be I mean I love Bobby and I just
we have a great dynamic too or we kind
of can flip it out flip out on each
other and get stolen you know so I'm
gonna go have lunch with Eric hey
honestly somebody needs to hang on to
that guy
all right listen this is called
shit-talking really quick it's just
quick questions quick answers from my
patrons they're just loyal fans who love
the podcast and are just I just love
them back here's LeeAnn what's been your
favorite podcast moments so far whiskey
ginger bad friends guest appearances
well what's the one moment you always
think about like I say every week
truthfully is the most fun I've ever had
on bad friend I love whiskey ginger cuz
I get to sit with one person in a room
and drink whiskey and talk [ __ ] you
never asked me thank you dude you have
to come through I mean dude honestly
it's been really challenging to be very
good dude well with this in the Pandy
like I'd rather I want to sit in a room
with you and drink the whole point of my
show was actually to really sit and have
a drink with someone to really talk to
them because I always feel like you know
whiskey's the lubrication of the soul so
I feel like you really do get some great
interesting conversation when you have a
drink with somebody and a lot of my
friends are sober which has been a
challenge but I'm a lightweight though
you get me drunk off one's one sip I'm
just gonna I'm gonna start kicked out of
Hollywood also he'll be saying why I do
the show because I want people to like
be honest but anyway bad friends every
week is great and whiskey ginger is
great but some some of the most fun
times I've ever had on a podcast were
inside you was Michael Rosemont no
honestly was any time I do ymh any time
I do your mom's house was Segura and
Christina it's always fun because I get
to go in there and I play this character
I get to play this character with them I
get to do this thing where I get he
leads me down these doors of like crazy
bits
I've created a fake relationship on
there where the guy named Rick who I
fell out of love with like I have this
love story on that show and it's just it
all that stuff is just fun improv you
still yapping I know this is questions
now
did you study acting no you know I
noticed cuz I watched some clips and
Mike Wow pretty impressed and then I
wanted to know I wanted to ask you that
I forgot to ask
I did I did journalism and English in
college was my minor so I did boring I
try to learn how to do ki TV talking you
know that's what I learned I try to
learn how to do that stuff in college
and then I did I did theater in college
but no it wasn't like I didn't go to
school for acting all right Raj love Raj
you adopted your adopted Indian bit as
hilarious what's the story behind
putting that character together oh my
god there's a guy named Raj Sharma oddly
enough
raaah Sharma who's a comic do you know
Raj you know rush on me ever heard him I
don't think so
doesn't mean anything if I don't know
long story about that bit I that bit was
like by the way that'll get me canceled
at some point I do in Indian accent
because Raj and I good friends and stand
up for years and whenever we I would do
the accent to him and Rogers always like
dude you got to do it on stage so I'm
not gonna do that on stage so stupid and
the crowd was so bad one night at laughs
actor he's like I'll give you a hundred
bucks if you do the Indian accent for
the whole set you have to do for the
whole set you can't break so I didn't I
did it it it ended up on you know their
YouTube and I got millions of views then
I had them take it down cuz I was like
that I wasn't that wasn't supposed to be
for the internet you know like I wanted
it just for the live show but they threw
it up there and then somehow it got
leaked a million times people do love it
do not have more a white person would be
like so racist I've had more Indian
people come up to me and be like we we
love that bit and I'm like I was just
kind of for the night you know but yeah
it came from Raj Sharma Raj L Raj unless
that's right look at that's Raj Sharma
asking you that do me a favor tell Raj
he's the best patreon ever best patron
ever in an adopted Indian accent Oh
patron yeah oh because he's a patreon
fan no no no he's a patron of mine he's
a page that I have a patreon account so
he's a patron patreon the patreon it's
like people they want extra foot bonus
stuff for the show I know but you're
saying patron its patreon patreon but
he's a patron of patreon forget it Roger
the greatest patron of patreon I've ever
seen man thank you so much for being a
part of the show we want to get inside
you sometimes
wow that's pretty you know how many
people have come up to me and say how
accurate is there's got there literally
people I don't want to say it's just
like if I was listening to somebody I'd
be like wow
that's you know I mean I do certain
things that I'm allowed to do like I
could do a pretty good Jewish you know
like I could do a good impression of my
grandfather you know he looked at me he
always look at me would ever go you're a
nut and now you're not look what is what
are you worried about what is it he
would that's how he sounded where's your
grandfather from New York Bronx by the
way can you can you do everybody does it
Harry Caray I probably do the best one
you'll ever hear
let's hear it oh you think you're better
than Will Ferrel yeah I think he over
does it okay I love Will Ferrell but we
always have to say that
what if it's my honest opinion I think
the best guy was John campanero this guy
this guy from this comedian
Campanelli no number John Campanella
John campanero Campanella I said right
didn't I yeah John campanero did the
best and he kind of taught me so all
right you tell me close your eyes
hazel fella Dave concepción house for
Havana Cuba where the Sun shines 365
days a year
and he misses a pop-up in the silent
Anna there's a trickler ground ball of
sale or the Durham hey check out the guy
in the sombrero high fly my love for you
that's very good that's very wills wills
is um what's the word wills is a funnier
yours is more accurate that's what I'm
saying yeah yours is more honest but to
be on SNL you got no no no it wills is
brilliant I'm just saying yes right his
is impression all that but I just
remember Harry he rhymes fan no but I
always had to watch him cuz I was in
Indiana cuz all they had was [ __ ]
Cubs and [ __ ] Braves and [ __ ]
Cardinals sorry guys who are you a fan
of I'm a Mets fan
I was born in New York but I grew up in
Indiana yeah sorry alright quickfire
marry B how soon do you think it will be
politically correct to joke about the
virus this virus crisis people been
joking about it the whole time what do
you mean people when there's so many
comic said I've been kidding about it
right now
I I you can joke about it if you want to
I don't know what's the joke that's what
I always say when someone's like which
too soon I don't know man what tell me
the joke tell me what the joke is now
it's usually never too soon if the joke
is funny you know Harlan a lot of people
taking shots at that like try to make
jokes
the viruses like I go ahead I don't know
I don't know what's fun what's funny
what am I gonna say Harlan said
something I thought was funny about
something people always but you know
they're the beginning when there was a
toilet paper shortage and they couldn't
get toilet paper and he's like and he's
like hey buzz like everybody's worrying
about the [ __ ] toilet paper so you
got a [ __ ] Stephen King's carry novel
up there [ __ ] you got you wipe your
ass with that novel for a good month
that's very good no there's plenty of
funny stuff that you could say about it
there's not it's never too early [ __ ]
make a joke about it I don't really know
I just nothing is too early to make a
joke about Lisa you went to ASU my alma
mater did you participate in the comedy
or improv group while there I used to
love watching the far side and bear in
mind perform at the mu between classes
Memorial Union that's right no I never
did I did stand-up I never tried to do
improv improv was never for me but those
guys were very talented I dunno who what
she's talking about in the basement and
the MU in the Memorial Union you could
you could walk by you could look down
and see people performing live in the
middle of the day they would do like
lunch matinee shows in the middle of the
day and the MU they were very funny
actually I do remember that very vividly
like they were good the farce I was good
bear in mind that gets so weird that's
like the same air as me she must've been
around the same time that I was there
Lisa
Todd what was your experience and I'm
dying up here do you think they had it
did it accurately depicting the world of
comedians oh man I don't know man that
was soon that show got canceled Todd
yeah I mean but you did two seasons
right no I know I'm kidding around yeah
no I think oh dude I don't know man do I
think it accurately depicts the world of
comedians I'm not I wasn't alive in 1973
so I couldn't really tell you but from
what I know from a lot of our critics in
terms of our critical peers you know a
lot of the older comics were like the
problem was the show was too serious it
didn't show the fun side and the crazy
side it show only showed kind of this it
was a dramatic show the show was a drama
it showed like the kind of the the
negative times and it wasn't a fair
depiction of what was going on back then
to be to be honest yes I think we
overdramatic sized a lot of things I
think the show's biggest downfall was
not being funny enough and it was all
about like kind of the sadness and the
heartache and the heartbreak and I do
agree that we deserve to be cancelled
because the show
didn't find its footing it was a lot of
great acting on that show but and great
writing but we didn't show enough love
there wasn't enough like having a really
good time because a lot of most comedy
whether it's 73 or no comics true you
know it's a fun come to the green room
the comic store wants you're like oh my
god he's got to having a great time I
remember being in the green room the
comedy store many times but like I think
you were there before but like with me
I'm a you obviously were there but like
Rogan and Rogan doing the stretches or
talking about things and and and just
things health-wise and like stretches
and just people goofing on each other
and meanwhile I had diarrhea cuz I'm a
new comic so I'm just [ __ ] all these
vet vets are talking I'm like oh my god
memorize what I'm gonna say I I have I
said to Swartz um one day I go uh I got
some you know some new stuff because all
your shits new dude you're [ __ ] new
you only have new [ __ ] new [ __ ] new [ __ ]
your new [ __ ] is your [ __ ] and [ __ ] your
new your new [ __ ] no yeah that's that
place I think that place is it's the
greatest place in the world we try to do
justice about the history of the store a
little bit but the show was was no I
didn't hate it our aim was good but what
we missed the target if that means
anything
yeah Bob Kay's comedy heart in the
current world it seems so many people
get offended so easily these days
everyone's being judged in the the court
of public opinion I said that is
rhetoric that is fake news I don't
believe that don't spread that around
Bob I think that's [ __ ]
this is this is one of these phrases
that people kind of regurgitate that I
don't buy anymore when somebody's like
Oh everybody is uh everyone's so PC what
can you say anymore really because not
at all I mean every comic I know that's
thriving right now look at across the
board
none of them are scared of what they're
saying to go look at the four specials
that just came out on Netflix segura
Kreischer D'Elia
what are you talking about everyone's
saying whatever the [ __ ] they want there
is this there is this weird there's this
weird rhetoric that gets like recycled
through society because some would
because somebody said it once like you
know Seinfeld was like you can't play
colleges anymore because they're too
sensitive and then everyone is like oh
my god everyone's so sensitive it's like
to come to the comedy store when the
the Comedy Store is the most is the most
groundbreaking say whatever you want
[ __ ] place I've ever been a part of
and none of it slowed down at all so I
don't buy that stuff I just yeah
people want to people want to make it
sound like people are too PC but guess
what there's millions of people that did
that just want comedy and they're not
looking to get offend could be as
politically correct incorrect as you
want as long as you I think I look as
long as you're just not stupid and
you're saying things that are just
really racist and [ __ ] belligerently
like it like for instance also new
comedians that are coming into it that
are just like getting up there they
don't have as such a what's the word you
guys sort of not not to have the right
to be politically correct but if you've
been doing it for years and years and
years you can get away with more
probably because people follow you right
well it's more about you it's more about
how you say it it's like huh it's not
it's not what you say but it's how you
say it so like if you if someone can
misconstrue what you say into something
politically correct maybe incorrect
maybe that's their perception of what
you're really saying if you're going
into something saying something with
with good intent and you want comedy out
of it and it doesn't have any like
vitriol or hate behind it that it's just
you making fun or light of something if
you snow how to say it right you can say
anything I mean Bill burr is a great
example you can say anything if you know
how to say it right you know how to make
it funny it's just you know yeah some
people just aren't funny and they say
dumb [ __ ] and then it gets him in
trouble and you're like well that was
your fault you just aren't funny
it wasn't rice rice I have a feeling
this is my producer cuz he likes you
since making the show Dave have you
thought about starting a rap career into
the name little cheeto that's very funny
no I'm never I'm never gonna have a rap
career yeah but but for Dave I will be
little Chi I'll be little cheeto li a
little cheetah lil lady lil wayne'
little Chino I love that I love that if
your name is Lilly you don't necessarily
have to be you know like I'm 6 1 but
I'll be little cheeto
you know because you can't be big cheeto
it sounds to cuz you have to be fat to
be called big you know what I mean so 4
lil little I'll be little cheat oh no no
rap career for me but I hope
hope I can still look at my dog just
came into my sex dungeon oh she's
looking she's looking at my plate she
wants your plate or she wants to black
what's that thing I named my dog after
my favorite baseball team the Chicago
Cubs
hey Andrew Santino's who makes you Vin
Scully VIN was due to Vince I love and
Scully yeah he'd go
a gerbil - down uh Canseco's up to bat
big arms big guy nice guy good guy and
that's one out - right he had this like
very like good snappy up and down like a
gerbil Dodger down I'm Josh Badger days
Dodger days here and Chavez Ravine there
there's a guy Bob Murphy for the Mets he
passed away many years but he had that
accent where he'd be like I want a
beautiful day for a ball game fans
phalion off the subway ramp now it's
honeydew season folks honeydew this and
honeydew that and my uncle went up to
him goes Bob Murphy [ __ ] Bob Murphy like
my favorite announcer he goes ooh that
is so very kind of you just had that and
on the ground ball through the middle
it's a base hit a base hit by Jimmy
crawls and it breaks up the perfect game
now the applause for Tom Seaver it just
it makes baseball cool because you just
feel so relaxed I miss it so much man I
miss baseball so much you don't have to
be there to be there it's the greatest
sport in the world that like if
someone's are gonna really like baseball
you're like you don't want to just go
hang out outside with friends what are
you talking about
really doesn't want to have a few beers
and just yell at people it's like when
somebody says they don't like golf and
they're like oh I don't I don't like
golf is like well have you ever tried it
and they go no it's like I don't know
we'll do that [ __ ] it's like dude name a
time when you can go drink beer outside
with friends for four hours
uninterrupted I am an eight like what do
you mean it's baseball and golf it's why
I love them both you can go hang out
with buddies you don't have to be good
you don't have to care about about the
game or your own personal you just go
hang out with friends it's it's it's
it's about camaraderie it has nothing to
do with anything else oh don't we all do
that
don't we all I'm sure you do but we all
do we're like that I don't know do that
when you have it and then you do it
you're like oh that's pretty cool I've
learned to be better actually over the
years I've learned to just go I'll try
it and then I try and if I still don't
like it I'm like no I tried it wasn't my
thing but more than ever I've been more
about go just going okay I'll I'll see
if that's its I'll see if it sucks like
I'll see if I really don't like it but
when you're young you're like no way but
when you get older I feel like you're
like I'll do it I don't forget what do I
gives you like I'm okay with being a
tourist I talk about that um I usually
talk about on stage I you should be so
afraid of being a tourist and now I'm
like I'm going to the Eiffel Tower
first thing I do like I don't give a
[ __ ] what do you mean I'm gonna die one
day I'm not gonna be the guy that went
to Roman didn't go to the Colosseum
you're an [ __ ] you're an [ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] I think that's right
and I can be an [ __ ] dude listen this
was a great time it really was and I and
you know I really other than like
meeting you a couple times and thinking
you're a funny guy in a nice guy
I really didn't know but I want to
congratulate you on bad friends I love I
love Bobby Lee I love you and I think I
think it's really funny and I really
enjoy watching it and and you what else
you got Dave Dave still going Dave is
our show on FX it's on Hulu now us cuz
FX is done showing it because the season
is done but go to who you can watch it
on Hulu if you have international fans
there it's all over it's BBC One it's on
the British networks now it's all over
Western and making its way to Eastern
Europe and then we'll be back for season
two hopefully in 2021 if the world isn't
totally burnt down to the ground so and
what's your handle what's your handle
buddy Cheetos Santino on Twitter and
Instagram and everywhere wherever you
can find me I'm its cheeto Santino CH e
eto sa NT I you know you following me no
huh and I think so I don't know I
actually don't know if you are know I
don't know that stuff either I don't I
don't pay much attention to it but
should I are you good on there are you
good on Twitter and sure yeah you'll
have some fun which one are you better
on
I don't know Instagram I I have a little
fun with you know I just do goofy [ __ ]
but I'm going through some of the
content and a lot of this is really
terrible to you with your shirt off no
no no no you gotta listen to it it's you
with your shirt off a lot of you with
your shirt oh that's not true
there's - with my shirt off maybe did
you ever think about getting a tattoo
above your penis that says Smallville
mmm I was gonna get one I'm not gonna
get into this dude listen this is a lot
of fun I want I hope I'm on whiskey
ginger I'd love to come on that's never
I want you to come on you'd be awesome
on that I love it hey good luck best of
luck with everything man you're doing
enjoy the success and I got nothing else
man this has been a good time thank you
for allow me to be inside of you buddy
thank you I love you I hope you guys
enjoyed today's podcast I appreciate you
all listening again thank you if you're
enjoying this
you know it's obviously free so
you know if you're you know joint
patreon er I don't know send an email
telling other people to listen to it or
write a review what's the deal I don't
know it's nicely to help out it really
is and I it means a lot to me so big
shout out to my patrons I love you you
know who you are
here we go Nancy D Mary bee I'm gonna
shoot him out here we go Lea asked
Trisha EFT sarahfey Yukiko Jilly Brian H
Lauren genie kopi Barry I bury L I think
it's Barry I why do I keep messing it up
Barry Angelina G Gerry w Kevin R Emily K
Rob be sorry Bob B Robert B don't get
confused with Bob being Robert B please
Jason W Kristin K Alison L ROG Sean W
Joshua D Emily SC JP Samantha M Hamza be
Jennifer n Stacy be carly t reand
Jennifer s Janelle be Tabitha - seven -
Kimberly
Melissa see Mikey Jake ambarisa n
jackass not jackass Jack s my boy Slater
Judah dear Amira Beth be Chris F Sarah f
JW Lee NP
hi Leanne hi Darla W Jackie P Roderigo
Roderigo s raishin raishin Rae a Mya P
Meagan D Demario I think that does it
for the top tier patrons a big shout out
to my friends at fat scooters they've
got great stuff and they're gonna do
some spots here later on but I they just
sent me a beautiful scooter and I love
it and it helps me during this time so
he just cruise around the neighborhood
with my mask but I love fat scooters pH
80 and they're not a sponsor but pop
OJ's right here I love this it's
popinjays like a vodka only different
made out of nectar from the flowers of
coconut trees pop o J's delivers a
smooth crisp taste perfect for cocktails
or on the rocks and you know what you're
gonna get $25 off for shipping
using the code Rosie 25 go to pop OJ's
PAP Oh Jas calm and it's HTTP colon
slash slash PAP ojs calm camp rosie is
still scheduled for October 31st have
them put out the event brights or
anything like that yet we're still
seeing what happens in this world and
right now the world is a little
upside-down but we'll let you know and
be on the lookout for some Instagram
lives love to join you thanks to my
patrons both patrons aware of all the
good horror movies gone my inside a
patron stay safe I hope you enjoyed this
one all right
[Music]